TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello, world.
I'm Timothy Jordan, reporting
for "The Developer Show"
here at the Firebase
Dev Summit in Amsterdam.
And I'm standing with
Francis Ma, the lead product
manager for Firebase.
Hi, Francis.
FRANCIS MA: Hey, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: How
are you doing today?
FRANCIS MA: Excellent.
Super excited to be
in Amsterdam today.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
This summit is way cool.
And my favorite
part is the keynote,
where we get to learn
all the cool new stuff
happening with Firebase.
And you talked
about two things I
was hoping that we could
get a few more details on.
Is that OK?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah, absolutely.
Would love to talk about it.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: The
first is Firestore.
Now, we know a little
bit about Firestore.
You talked about it a little
bit more in the keynote.
Just lay it out for us.
What is Firestore, and why
is it great for developers?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
Firestore is our next
generation's Firebase database.
And the really
cool part about it
is that it's a NoSQL
document-based database that
scales automatically.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And what
is it that it solves now
that we couldn't do before
with other solutions?
FRANCIS MA: So there
were two things.
First off, we built
Firestore based
on the learnings from
the Realtime Database,
and have done so building
on Google's powerful cloud
infrastructure.
And so with that, the first key
part is the scalability of it.
And as I mentioned
earlier that Firestore
is an auto-managed
database-- what that means is
as a developer, you
don't have to worry
about the infrastructure.
It just scales
effortlessly, whether you're
building a prototype,
running a startup,
or even scaling up to,
say, a billion users.
It will just automatically
work for you.
And the second part that's
really cool about Firestore
is that its data
structure is now
based on a collections
document model, which
is a change from the
Firebase Realtime Database.
And with this new
model, it allows
you to structure your data a
little bit more intuitively
and also be able to run
efficient queries on it as
well.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All right.
Let's talk about
one other thing,
and that's Firebase
Predictions, which you announced
for the first time today.
Tell us-- what is it?
FRANCIS MA: Yeah.
We're super excited
about Predictions.
It's our first step of bringing
Google's machine learning
into Firebase.
And we have created
this to help developers
apply machine learning on
their own analytics data
and predict what their
users are likely to do.
And so the power in
there is that now they
can take more proactive
actions to create a more
engaging experience
for their users.
So, for example, if
you're building a game,
we can help you predict
how likely users are going
to leave your game because
they may find it too difficult.
And so now, as a
game developer, you
will be able to use it to
say whether you give them
some promotion up front or lower
the difficulty of the level
to continue to drive
that engagement.
And the cool part
about Predictions
is that you can also set up
your own custom predictions.
So it not only works
well for game developers,
but, say, if you're building
an e-commerce app or a fitness
app, you can set up
your own predictions
that are important for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's really cool.
I think my favorite thing
about Firebase Predictions
is that all of that machine
learning is under the hood.
We did all the hard work,
and developers can just
use the value of it.
FRANCIS MA: Absolutely.
And that's really the
spirit of Firebase,
where our focus is to
help developers focus
on creating value
for their users
and us doing the heavy
lifting for them.
And in this instance,
for machine learning,
a lot of developers
that we've heard from
are finding some of
the tools on the market
difficult for the fact that
it requires advanced machine
learning knowledge.
And so here, following
the Firebase spirit,
we have packaged a lot
of it under the hood,
as you had said,
such that there is
no need for them to have any
machine learning knowledge
whatsoever.
All they need to do is
enable this feature.
As long as they have
analytics enabled,
the machine will just work
and automatically set up
Predictions for you.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Francis, thanks
so much for joining us today.
FRANCIS MA: Always my pleasure.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks
for joining me here
at the Firebase Dev
Summit 2017 in Amsterdam.
For links to all the session
videos, look in the description
below.
I'm Timothy Jordan for
"The Developer Show."
See you next time.